- So on "The Morning Show",
which I love, great show,
is it accurate to say
that you are now the youngest
host ever for the show?
- On the show, yes.
- On the show, yes
For UBA, yeah, which
is a fake news network,
but thank you so much.
(Kelly laughs)
- I'm a pioneer.
- I'm breaking ground, hypothetically.
(Kelly laughs)
- But I hear that there's something
that happened on your Instagram,
like when you got on the
show, people were going crazy.
- Oh, people are losing it on IG.
So I, as you can see in the clip,
I'm clean shaven in the
show, because I am acting,
but people on Instagram weren't having it.
They love me with the
melanin, with the beard.
- I do like the beard.
- And they were all up in the
comments and they were livid.
(Kelly laughs)
- Okay. Well, okay.
So it did spark, you know,
outrage on Instagram.
So I want to show you some
of the comments, everybody.
Looking young, like you
work at Foot Locker.
(Kelly laughs)
(hands clapping)
- Okay.
- Awesome.
- I see that a little bit.
All right, that works.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- Yeah.
- It's the clean as the baby-butt smooth.
- Yeah, it's like my first job.
I'm 15.
- Yeah, exactly
- It's somewhat legal.
My parents are like, "Go make money."
And I'm like, "All right,
I'll work at Foot Locker.
(Kelly laughs)
- That's a good job.
So wait, so this is a good one.
Okay. You look bomb either
way but, damn, that shave.
(laughs)
- Wait, but is that good or bad, Kelly?
- I mean, it's good.
It's like, you look good
either way, but like, "Damn,
I like the beard."
That's how I feel like-
- Let's open this up to the people.
- Let's...
(laughs)
- I'm talking about you,
weird digital screens
and I'm talking about the people here.
What do you guys think?
We go beard or we go clean shave?
(Crowd claps)
- [Kelly] The beard.
- Beard or clean shave?
(crowd clapping)
- [Kelly] I think most women
are going to say beard.
- Beard?
- [Kelly] Yeah, it's just nice.
The beard is nice.
- Okay, beard it is.
- [Kelly] I mean, you look
great though on the show.
- Thank you.
- Great job.
(laughs)
Well, wait, something
scary recently happens
on your comedy tour.
So could you tell us about it?
- So I'm on tour.
This is just this past weekend.
I'm in Detroit.
- [Kelly] Yes.
And you know, if you're
familiar with my comedy,
it's kind of like, you
know, just NPR, PowerPoint,
fun jokes.
(Kelly laughs)
- You know what I mean?
- Which is great.
- Yeah, it's a good vibe.
I'm in the green room and I'm
in the green room in Detroit
at the beautiful Fox Theatre.
I hear someone's screaming
in the lobby and I'm like,
"What is going on?"
The show hasn't even started.
And they're like, "Well,
you know it is Detroit.
"Crazy things can happen."
I'm like, "Yeah, not at
the Hasan Minhaj show."
(Kelly laughs)
I send Prashanth, our director.
I go, "Go find out what's going on.
"We got to start the show."
He goes out into the lobby
and he goes, "There's an
Indian guy with a bomber jacket
"who looks just like you.
"He's with his dad.
"And his dad is like
slinked on his shoulders."
And I'm like, "Indian
dads don't do Jager Bombs.
"Like, that's not possible.
"Go fix it."
And they basically go, "Hey,
is someone here a doctor?"
And then, you know,
it's obviously my show,
so 50 Indian people are
going, "I'm a doctor."
(Kelly laughs)
So they start crowding
around, "I'm a doctor."
And they start one-upping
each other, right?
And like, "Get over here.
"Get him a garbage bag,
"Get Dad a garbage bag."
I'm like, "Oh my God,
"this is like a huge insurance risk here."
Uncle projectile vomits all
over his Kirkland Signature
khakis and his Costco shoes.
And the doctor shows up and
goes, "Everybody out of the way,
"everybody out of the way.
"It's okay.
"We can start the show.
"Uncle just did edibles
for the first time."
- Oh my gosh.
- Yes.
- That's so rock and roll.
- Yeah!
And I'm like, "People are
doing edibles at my show?"
(Kelly laughs)
(crowd claps)
I think I really made it.
- I mean it's a cool way
to see a comedy show.
- Yeah.
- You really get into the moment.
- I love that.
And it was a very Indian
something to do to be like,
"Yeah, we're going to learn,
but we're also going to get high."
(Kelly and crowd laughs)
- Wait, so you're a father of two.
- Yes.
- How old are they?
- I have a three-year-old
and a one-year-old.
- Wow!
So my kids were the same,
about two years apart as well.
That's...
You're tired.
- I'm super tired.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm very tired right now.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] I was going to
say, "You're not sleeping."
- [Hasan] Not at all.
- [Kelly] Aww.
- Yeah.
Aw, that's me and baby girl.
And look, we're having just
a daddy-daughter moment.
And I thought I was...
You know, one of the things
I love doing is just like,
when we have a moment, we can kiss,
we share our little bond,
but then she got marker all
over my sweatshirt, which-
- Oh man.
They do that.
My daughter is really
into just carrying the pen
around like this,
because she's writing
sentences now, she's seven.
And I'm like, "That's
exciting. Put the lid on."